foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell joined by my
good friend and much smarter friend Dr
John deloney and we are here to answer
your calls about money life mental
health relationships marriage the
boundaries that you don't have with your
in-laws it all happens right here in
front of you on the Ramsay show so give
us a call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five Kaylin joins us up
first in Columbus Kalin welcome to the
show
hi can you hear me yes how are you doing
um I'm really stressed so hopefully you
can help me oh boy we can try our best
John's here and he always calms me
okay good George says I'm his walking
Xanax so I can help let's do this
all right so my question is should I and
if the answer is yes how do I do this
um set boundaries with my mom in regards
to her constantly asking me for money
oh that one's hard how long has this
been going on for
[Music]
yeah it got a little bit better because
my sister moved in with her and had been
like paying for a lot of stuff but my
sister just got herself into a lot of
credit card debt going on a vacation she
couldn't afford and so
um so you're the functional one of the
family
yeah and so they all come to you because
they go well Caitlyn's got her life
figured out we'll ask her for money and
she'll give it to us because she's so
sweet
if your mom's been asking you for money
for seven years that means you're giving
her money for seven years is that right
yeah I mean
Payless you have to quit beating
yourself up you love your mom
and it's hard to tell your mom no
especially when Mom is violating what I
would consider a core tenant of that
parent-child relationship and using you
almost predatorily that's hard so don't
beat yourself up for that okay
like you're good you've been doing the
best you could to maintain that
relationship even though that's not your
job and you've been trying to take care
of your mom because probably she's
struggling a lot right
yeah it's really hard because
um she's on disability and can't work so
her income is fixed and it's really low
and so
um I mean it doesn't help that she
doesn't budget either but when she gets
to the end of the month she never has
any money so she'll call me and be like
hey Caitlin I am at a gas station I have
no gas and I have no money will you send
me some yeah
so what was your never again moment why
why now why are you calling what
happened
um because last week her water heater
broke and everyone in my family was like
texting me like hey you know your mom
can't afford to fix that and they're
just expecting me to like give out this
money to fix this water heater
um and luckily my grandparents paid for
it and I didn't have to but
I just I can't keep doing this we're on
like
um myself and I just started
um like this month like really intensely
working on
um baby steps too or trying to pay off
our debt
um
and I just
I just can't be doing this so
there's a great quote and I'm going to
butcher it a little bit by
um a therapist that I hold in high
regard his name is Terence real Terry
real
and the the gist of the quote is
family dysfunction roles downhill from
generation to generation like a forest
fire through a family
until one Brave person
has the courage to stop and turn and
stare the forest fire down and in doing
so gives peace to ancestors they will
never know
and that's what you're doing right now
and here's the the part about that quote
that doesn't get talked about is when
you turn and face it
when you turn and face that dysfunction
you say no more never again you're gonna
get burned right you're gonna get hurt
your family members are gonna say I
can't believe you're abandoning mom you
have all this money and you're not even
and it's gonna hurt when they do that
and they don't get a vote
and when your mom chooses to not budget
to choose to not live in reality that's
hard that's not your job to fix
will there be a day that she might have
to move in with you possibly so you
better get your house in order ASAP
right
um yeah it's not just magic so you're
doing the hard work
I I wish George and I could give you a
magic pill that would say just say these
four sentences in this conversation is
easy and it goes away it's just it's not
how this works
you're gonna get spit on you're going to
be told you're ungrateful how dare you I
can't believe you
um
and you're gonna have to stand firm
knowing the greatest thing long term for
your family is a safe secure Kalin whose
house is in order
it's hard
yeah go ahead the other way or to this
is that my younger brother also lives
there and he just turned 18 and he's
developmentally disabled
um and so I feel like if I don't give my
mom money then like I don't know if he's
gonna eat
then if you're worried about him then
that's a conversation between you and
your husband about whether he moves in
with y'all or you go sit down with a
um
with some of the Community Resources and
you're where you live and you look at
long-term care housing options that are
Community funded but here's the thing
just throwing money at this problem when
you know your mom is not responsible
with that money you don't know that he's
going to eat even if you do give her
money
because if that was a question if she
was choosing to spend money on other
stuff or him eat
she's gonna she's gonna do that whether
she's got money or not
that's like that's that's character
stuff right
yeah yeah what's the nature of your
mother's disability
so
um she has a seizure disorder but also
um
she can't really stand or walk very well
um my other brother was abusive for a
long time and um like beat her so badly
that her knees are completely shot oh
good it's awful what a mess but you said
she's driving you said she's getting gas
yeah she can drive okay I'm just trying
to think if there's a way out of this
long term versus you know I'm not mad at
taking disability from the government
but if there's a way for her to make
more income than that and have a better
quality of life and to where you're not
having to be the government for her then
I'd rather us aim for that and you help
her get there
or if you do give her money and you
decide to work that into your budget
that you pay X Bill and you pay that
bill directly to the electrician or you
or the electric company or to the water
company or wherever you happen to do
that but I'm not just going to keep
putting money in a black hole
um or I'm going to take two or three
years and really work harder than mom's
going to move in with us or whatever
that looks like that's part of you
owning reality there but
it's a mess there is no easy way out of
this when you say no more
it's hard thanks for the call Colin
we're wishing you the best this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five don't be scared give
us a call we'll talk through your
biggest worries concerns questions we'll
celebrate with you don't be scared don't
be scared they used to be like the no
fear shirts when I was in high school
it's more for the younger generation
they're like I didn't know my phone
could make phone calls that's true
there's an anxiety about getting a human
phone yeah you know this I do so that's
who I was talking to gotcha the ones who
are like they get a phone call they get
spooked
one day the show would just be us
texting back and forth with screen
recording no the Bots will just do it
for us they don't need us at that point
we'll be out of a job well hey our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
their Nationwide network of locally
owned home service pros like Molly Maid
shelf Genie and Mr Appliance take the
stress out of home repairs maintenance
and improvements visit neighborly.com to
schedule a service today today's
question comes from Dylan in Maryland
Dylan asks why do you recommend I love
that you know who starts questions like
that my seven-year-old but that's cool
why do you recommend paying off my
mortgage that has a low interest rate
that provides a tax deductions instead
of keeping the money invested where I'm
getting a higher return on that interest
this seems like an illogical Financial
approach yeah George Dylan should be
hosting the show this guy has cracked
the code man I know he's smarter clearly
he's smarter than you he's a genius
because you're illogical I I'm gonna be
honest I'm exhausted by this question
John because we have had a historically
low mortgage rates so everyone got these
crazy low mortgage rates of
two and a half three percent three and a
half percent and then now interest rates
on savings accounts are like four
percent so like I'm never paying off my
mortgage you're an idiot if you pay it
for mortgage early dude this is a money
making scheme go invest in the stock
market instead of paying off your
mortgage and I'm going where are they
getting guaranteed returns of 10 in the
stock market now we say long term the
stock market has seen 10 to 12 on
average
but assuming that in a given year it's
not going to be I don't know negative 18
like it was in 2021 that is a wild
starry-eyed approach to finances and
there's a whole other piece of this
which you can speak to which is the
freedom and peace of not having a house
payment goes so much further than just a
math equation on paper yeah I call it um
my soul tax or a sleep tax
um I I've heard it called several
different things but
for three or four percentage points on
an annual return to not have a house
payment nobody can take away my house I
can get fired tomorrow and it'd be
annoying and not devastating
um
I I it's hard for me to even put a price
on that and if you look at some of the
data emerging about anxiety and your
body's response to how much money you
owe you might think in your fancy pants
prefrontal cortex that you uh got a
great deal and quite honestly you did
you got a good deal you're making a good
return against your three percent APR on
your house you're making nine percent
you're making six percent
but your amygdala knows the part of your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
knows at any moment we lose our home
right and so even the idea George of
debt on your house is so relatively new
given our the human psychology right
over the last thousands and thousands of
millions of years
just the idea that someone's saying I
just want to keep owing a bank my money
on my house instead of it being mine in
my in my children's and my children's
Children's is insane I'll just put it
that way but yes Dylan let's call it up
you are right you are right you can have
a 2.8 percent APR on your house and you
can invest that money and right this
moment in history you can you can you
can cover the Gap you can cover that
spread
but I promise you I sleep better than
you do
that's all that's fair well there's
another piece of this that he mentioned
that really it my gears had half been
grinded well and that's the
technological gears this whole idea of
tax deductions and we walk through this
in Financial Peace University but I'm
like how bad are you at math that you
think sending ten thousand dollars to
your mortgage lender in interest is
better than sending two thousand dollars
to the IRS
that's what you're doing you're stepping
over a dollar to pick up a quarter and
thinking that you're winning and the
mortgage companies love this they're
like great send us more interest instead
of the IRS we're way better than the IRS
that's what you're doing and by the way
almost nobody itemizes on their taxes
anymore everyone takes the standard
deduction which means you don't get to
deduct your mortgage interest
almost nobody's doing this so This
theoretical idea that you're doing it
for the tax deductions is wildly
illogical and by the way you can't
compare your interest you're making in a
savings account to your mortgage
interest
it's different it's weighed way in the
favor of interest when you get that
mortgage go look your amortization
schedule and you'll see you're going I
paid 600 in interest on my mortgage that
has a three percent interest rate my
savings account only made forty dollars
this month so you can't weigh the two
against each other unless you have the
full amount of your mortgage sitting in
a savings account then on paper you
might be able to say temporarily that
you can beat it
I hadn't thought of that George
a Philly on me man but that's actually
really why so
if I owe five hundred thousand dollars
and I'm paying two percent
I and I'm getting
five percent or six percent in a in a
savings account on my ten thousand
dollars that's not apples to Apple no
because I'm paying all my interest up
front on that mortgage exactly it's
front loaded in a significant way
well there you go being logical I don't
I they call me a drink Crusher when I
say these things John I'm like this guy
doesn't know what he's talking about
here's here's like what like when it
comes down to it
the house you had
um that you the house you paid off
I'm assuming because of when you bought
it your interest rate was low yeah I
think it was three six two five okay
mine was two eight five I know super
super you're an idiot for paying it off
John you could have made so much money
but I guess the proof in the pudding is
this isn't us just throwing mathematical
theories up against the wall this is how
we just live our lives right yes and
it's not a game or it's not like yeah no
it's I I'm this is how we live well on
the other part we didn't mention was you
know what you can do when you don't have
a mortgage payment you could invest a
mortgage payment and start doing the
math on what that turns into and the
options it gives you and the options to
do the things that people like Dylan
want to do which is retire early
I don't know maybe you want to give more
you have some outrageous giving goals
spending goals you want to take the
family on a cruise it's just harder to
do that when you've got a mortgage
around your neck that's right and so
like John said I'm sleeping better I'm
living better I'm investing better and
I'm okay with the like I could have made
more if I you will go crazy thinking
about the what ifs and what if I
invested in the market and what if I got
in on bitcoin 10 years ago and what if I
got on an Uber you can't live with the
what ifs I just go with what is the
reality of my present and the reality is
I don't have a mortgage payment so I'm
going to sleep better or the reality is
I have to give somebody money every
month or they will take my house from me
and I don't want that in my life right
it's just as simple as I don't I don't
want to owe somebody for my home and I I
really honestly don't care what that
cost me
it's the people George were talking to
during the last three years on the
student loan interest pause
that just saw a golden opportunity to
pay all this stuff off with no interest
and then there's those the vast majority
of folks 99 to be went and uh bought new
cars and bought new mortgages because
the rates were so low and they're going
to find themselves in a mess here in a
couple of months yeah interest is a
maddening game whether it's zero percent
or three percent and you think you're
winning because you can get a spread on
the interest rate but think about all
the mental calories you're burning just
trying to play a game created by lenders
and by this broken toxic Financial
system designed to keep you broke they
love that you are losing sleep thinking
about the spread on interest rates all
the while the folks who are debt free
are going oh I haven't thought about
debt in years well you've just been over
here living our life and so it's a
different game it's chess and checkers
and we're out here trying to teach y'all
how to play some
yeah that's true I haven't played chess
and you're illogical no I'm not that
good I've seen the Netflix show though
that was an interesting one oh the
Gambit yeah I didn't watch it yeah it's
all right we'll get you there too busy
getting smarter too busy paying off a
mortgage and stuff well hey it's a fun
question it's a fun conversation I hope
we answered it Dylan I don't know that
you're pleased but people like Dylan
they're hard to please John very hard to
please more of your questions coming up
AAA
825-5225 this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
much
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this is the Ramsay show
we're talking about your life your money
relationships the stuff that matters to
you and we want to hear from you that's
the show it's you if it's just us us two
hanging out here it's a terrible show I
need you guys to make it great we don't
even like hanging out with each other
terrible but uh if you want to join the
conversation you can call the number
888-825-5225 Hayden has chosen to do
that has been uh selected to make it
through Celine has chosen the
contestants like he's heading into the
Matrix or something you weirdo hey and
welcome to the show
thank you guys appreciate you I also I
want to thank you for you know being
part of my inspiration over the past
couple months and me and my daughter
listen to you guys in the podcast every
morning on our run so appreciate it well
that's incredible we're appreciative of
that how can we help today absolutely
okay so once you guys input on this so
just a little insight 22 years old
married with a nine month old I'm in
school right now I have two jobs one of
which is our business I mean my wife run
I'm looking to get a third job because
we're looking to pay off some debts I
did fall into the trap a few months back
where I thought I had to you know
um get get in debt or have money to make
more money and then
I my parents are Ramsey people and so
they reintroduced me and so now I'm back
on track so
question today for you guys is I have
two options for a third job that I'm
looking for
some of which is basically like an
additional full-time job that would
require me to work Sunday through
Thursdays from seven or ten PM to 7 A.M
and then I'd be jumping into my
full-time job from 8 AM and then finish
up around like four or five
and that would bring in another four
thousand dollars a month for us
or my second option would be picking up
like a like part-time real retail job
and it'd probably take us like twice as
long to pay off the money but it would
be have to work so that's just kind of
my dilemma I'm in like the super gazelle
intense mode right now the first option
as well would require me to put off
school for one semester to finish it
what are you studying
business how close are you being done
so I just got my associates and I'm
doing school more part-time than
full-time and cash flowing it all
how much debt do you owe
so it's 27 500.
what are you hoping to do with a
business degree
very entrepreneur minded but
also I enjoy the job I'm at now and open
to like another job and just kind of
have a business on the side to fulfill
that entrepreneurial what's the business
you and your wife are running
yeah so we do turo where we own a few
cars and then we manage other people's
cars as well oh and you went into debt
for these cars
yeah correct how much money are you
making you were like
so on the best month we've done we did 6
000 in profit and then last month was
the worst and we broke even after paying
off
um so zero dollars what if I told you to
go sell those two cars
um I would be open to it I've thought
about it
um
you know we we definitely could get out
that way
um only like only reason why like I keep
thinking about just paying them off is
because I do like having that extra
income and knowing that like we get paid
off bro it was zero dollars last month
yeah I know it's because like Arizona no
one wants to come here okay during the
summer time hey now I want you to win
and calling this a business is frivolous
that would be like me saying hey I own a
business what do you do I drive for Uber
right and so I understand that like
Turtle people can do this and you saw
some tick tocks and this guy was like
dude just get going to debt for like 17
cars and then you flip those and you get
the money from turo and the cars are
depreciating assets which makes this a
not a great business model
for sure so if you sold these cars would
you get out of debt completely
I would yep and I would still have a
couple of cars that we bought and then
here's what it would happen you can
actually sleep because the plan you just
laid out for us means you will might be
able to eat a meal and you might be able
to get two hours of sleep
right with a nine month old
and depreciating assets that you're
trying to pay off like it it doesn't
make sense as a dad does it make sense
as a new husband does it make sense as a
23 year old guy I'm all for you
finishing that degree that's going to be
a good uh tool in your in your tool in
your toolkit
bro sell the cars man
and listen if if you
after 30 to 60 days of not owing anybody
any money as a brand new dad and you and
your wife have no fights about money and
um you just miss the excitement then go
take out loans and go buy two more cars
yeah I'm almost 100 positive that's not
gonna happen the plan you laid out with
working 22 hours a day that's that's not
viable man
yeah that's not viable you're right I
get it but it's not viable I'd much
rather see you work full time get done
with school and be 25 years old with a
your business degree you've got several
years of working full-time and you're
ready to go Take On The World at that
point
yeah
I see that
and for whatever it's worth I didn't get
my first full-time job in in higher ed
as at a university until I was at the
end of being 20 uh no it was is almost
26.
and so you haven't even started yet bro
does that make sense yeah I know I'm I'm
a very impatient person that I've been
working on yeah yeah but that impatience
you learned it at a young age but that
impatience got you two cars that are
depreciating assets that you're trying
to work 22 hours a week to pay off it's
just doesn't if to get a job that some
months
breaks even
because it's too hot where you live yeah
so I just wouldn't I wouldn't uh you
laid it out in front of us and we do
what we tell you we would do and that is
a scary situation I'm getting out of
this thing and I'm gonna start a real
business down the line when I'm ready
but for now sell the cars dude the turo
people are coming after you man I mean I
like turtle I think it's a really cool
idea what is it it's where I can rent
John deloney's car and drive it around
for a rental fee
so you can list your car like an Airbnb
list your house for rent just like your
with your car so it seems like the
people who have a vested interest in
that gig is the car dealerships whose
business is getting taken out from under
them by online sales that they have
these fleet of cars out in their lots
that they can just rent out on the
weekends yeah I mean it's competing with
the car rental companies it's kind of
taking it into our own hands which on
some levels is great because you can
rent with a debit card with no issues
and it's really slick and I can just go
on the app and choose a car and in my
area and do it without even seeing a
person and they can remotely unlock it
there's all kinds of things they can do
so it's a pretty cool feature but I'm
not going to make that a business model
and I've seen some of these guys on
Instagram where they go I got a fleet of
seven cars and this is my business and
that's fine that can be a legitimate
business but doing with debt just adds
way too much risk we have different
Instagram feeds just FYI I don't know
what has happened John the algorithm is
like we will punish this man give him
everything that will just make them yeah
very different Instagrams what's on on
your Instagram
um just workout videos mostly workout
videos and architecture and a couple of
guys in the Everglades catching snakes
that's about it I take it back that also
is my nightmare I don't know my ideal
Instagram algorithm is but it's not
dudes catching snakes and it's not
protein powders well it's yours is like
all right bro money making hack 4007.
you're right let's do it in hindsight
your sounds are way better but I cannot
tell you John you probably get this too
so many people send us videos and the
DM's going have you guys seen this what
do you think about this what would
Ramsay say and half the time it's just a
person who's real excitedly telling you
how to make a lot of money fast yeah and
the faster wrong yeah and the more
excited they are and the faster they say
I'm gonna make it the less I trust them
and the quicker you should just run away
in the other direction right because
usually they have some scammy get rich
quick course to sell you their life
insurance salesman half the time telling
you why 401ks are stupid and why their
insurance plan is going to beat the
stock market somehow that that's most of
the videos I get anymore it's it's a
much different ones 25 year old kid
calling you illogical
because they've they've figured out the
hack they solved the issue they solved
it we figured it out man we're just
gonna do we're gonna write off the taxes
and become millionaires we start the LLC
we're gonna become millionaires with our
tax write-offs we're gonna solve aging
we're figuring it all out Jordan a
million dollars in a line of credit
invest that money open an LLC right off
the Range Rover as part of that boom
you're a bajillionaire that's social
media advice with a Range Rover and
we're the dream Crushers telling you
maybe just stay out of debt I don't know
invest for the future and live a
peaceful life you're near not as
exciting not very sexy gosh we're
terrible no one's ever called us sexy
George ever that's fair all right more
of the Ramsay show coming right up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
baloney if you're a new listener to the
show we are so grateful that you're here
we're glad you found us however you
found us and if you want a deeper dive
on this stuff there's a lot of Insider
talk a lot of lingo a lot of baby steps
we want to help you take the right Next
Step at ramseysolutions.com click on the
get started button and we would be happy
to help you figure that out
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
Lakeisha joins us in Cleveland up next
Lakeisha welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um so the reason I'm calling today is
because I'm engaged to be married and in
the February of next year
and me and my fiance are going back and
forth of whether or not to pause the
baby steps to Castle the wedding or do
both at the same time
okay so the wedding's in February how
much debt do you have
oh gosh
um
that was incredible oh gosh
um about between both of us is about 200
000. what kind of debt is that
um
students mostly
are you are you a doctor
no me this is more
more than
um he is a social worker and I'm a mail
carrier so I'm not even using mine
what's his degree in social work in
social work yeah George is not in honors
classes I'm just
to be a social worker yeah so
is he an lmsw
um yes okay so that's that's graduate
school too
yes yes he has about 150 000. gosh
what is your income
um I make about 78
good a thousand okay what team is
she makes about 70 off though okay so
once you're married you'll combine bank
accounts and that will be y'all's income
but for now we've got to focus on your
debt he's got to focus on his debt and
at the same time we need to make a plan
for how we're paying for this wedding
now yeah there's a few options here
number one is you go to the courthouse
and you get this thing done and we have
a big celebration after the debt's paid
off and we can pay for a party for
everyone
that's option number one
you don't like that lakisha's not having
it hates that one no go to plan two
George plan two is we have a very
reasonable wedding and we pay cash for
it I don't like the idea of pausing the
debt payoff process in order to just
save up and pay for an extravagant party
for other people so what is this wedding
going to cost
um
eighteen thousand how much cash do you
guys have between the two of you
um not much right now
so probably just a few thousand if that
yeah yeah yeah
Lakeisha can I can I be super direct
with you because I feel like we're best
friends now
of course of course
I hate to say what I'm about to say
y'all are broke and y'all are scary
broke
you're marrying somebody who is
committed to serving his community he
has a graduate degree he's I'm confident
that he's very very smart they don't
just hand out lmsws
and you are adding significant value to
your community your community only works
because someone like you is is in it and
and committed to it
but y'all are scary scary broke
and I don't mean to say that to be like
uh like I don't know to try to start
fires where there's no need to but
you guys have to get it through your
heads that y'all owe 200 000 plus
dollars
that's a house
and it's not a house right and so I
understand the dream of the wedding and
you've had this dream since you were
little you have this picture in your
head of what this is going to look like
and I think you can still make it happen
and right now you don't have anything
man you gotta pay this thing off
[Music]
so here's the problem if we said hey
don't get married until the debt's paid
off well that could be three four years
from now right
so I don't like that plan if you guys
are ready emotionally spiritually
mentally to be together to be married we
want you to do that as soon as you can
and it doesn't have to involve a giant
party that you throw for other people
because truthfully that's what it is yes
they're celebrating you but that hundred
bucks a person is what you're paying for
you're paying for their meal for their
stuff and hopefully they give you a nice
gift but at this point 200 Grand of the
whole it's only going to set you back
further to spend another 200 Grand to 20
grand to go into debt for this wedding
because you don't have the money
right I mean right now are you guys able
to pay bills let alone set aside money
for this wedding
it's working seven days a week
um so yeah we're trying
but I mean like I said it's been really
more focused on trying to get money
because we've put deposits down on stuff
as well so that's on my other issue how
far how far down the rabbit hole are you
how much how much money are you in
already
okay
well it's not a lot but we've like
signed contracts with people
yeah
that's pretty serious yeah
I would I would here's what I would do
I want you and it's going to sound
ridiculous I want you to actually grieve
this wedding that you wanted to have
and it sounds silly like oh my gosh
there's so many people in the world with
bigger problems you're right
but this is still heartbreaking
because you had this picture that was
gonna happen and you went to college and
your husband went to grad school and
both of y'all are service oriented
people y'all deserve this right
and you've also put yourself in a little
bit of a hole because you put two
thousand dollars in deposits down to
various vendors and so I want you to
have some sort of moment some sort of
miniature ceremony for what was this is
what it was going to be
and then I want you to look at the
deposits you've put down and how small
yet beautiful yet honorable wedding you
can have with the deposits you've put
down
and get out of this thing and throw a
big blowout the blowout of the century
when you two are able to breathe and
stand up on your own two feet because
you owe nobody anything
that to me is is is also worthy of
Celebration it's an Independence Day
right it's Freedom yeah yeah
and here's the other piece Lakeisha the
sooner you guys get married the sooner
you can combine bank accounts and
combined incomes the sooner you can pay
off this debt there is Magic when you
have dual incomes attacking the debt
together it's just a game changer so I
don't want you just delaying this to pay
off the debt I don't want you drawing a
huge wedding now while you're in the
debt both of those aren't good options
so I think we need to find some Middle
Ground here we go we're going to do a
real small backyard ceremony we're going
to do the courthouse thing we'll throw a
huge party later but right now we got to
focus on just climbing out of this hole
that we've been and your friends are
going to give it to you your family are
you kidding me you're not gonna yep you
guys make too much money to be doing
this we are changing our family tree and
hey a wedding gift for you
um we're gonna send you Financial Peace
University and one year of the every
dollar app so that when y'all get
married y'all can combine this thing
it'll help you work together it combines
with your bank it puts everybody on the
same page and it's a tool that y'all can
use I want you to watch this videos
together go through that stuff together
and it will help you either get on the
same page or we'll clarify some hard
conversations you'll need to have as
you'll head into this in this meeting
this to this marriage either way
but yeah phew George that's tough man I
wish I had good answers for you Lakeisha
that just made you smile but this is one
of those tough situations where I can't
in good faith go to bed tonight knowing
I told Lakisha have the wedding of your
dreams if this was any other purchase we
would say you're broke you can't afford
that vacation you can't afford that car
and a wedding is no different while it's
special and it's spiritual the idea that
we have to always spend 20 30 40 50 I
had one call 500 000 on a wedding is
just insane and I also want to call out
because of the choices we're making on a
daily basis
some of these things what I would call
Core
cultural values
um buying a home
um having a an extravagant celebration
of two families coming together and two
people heading off to create a new
adventure together we're having to pause
or minimize or Crush those because of
the daily decisions we're making about
buying stupid cars by going 200 000 in a
student loan debt so we've got to have a
cultural conversation about hey we are
cashing out on these institutions that
matter just so we can eat on Friday we
gotta change the way we live George yeah
man weddings are too important they're
too beautiful they're too important that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books I'm George Campbell he's John
deloney we'll be back before you know it
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John baloney and
we are excited enthused to take your
calls at AAA
825-5225 if you need some confirmation
affirmation inspiration whatever you're
going through whatever's keeping you up
at night we want to help you take the
right Next Step some constipations we
can't give you that I don't know that we
can relieve that I am certain we can
give you constipation John has been
known to do that and he's very very good
at it he's a he's got a PhD I don't know
what it's in but apparently he's got one
in in it's in my PhD is in the inability
to go to the bathroom there are Dumber
degrees out there so it would not Shock
me at this point that's probably fair
but we'll get there regardless of how
many degrees John has we can help
hopefully what are all those Asians you
dropped out inspiration affirmation
confirmation constipation motivation
that's not in there you keep throwing
that one in there all right stop trying
to make it happen all right all right
Jeremy is up first if he still even
wants to talk to us Jeremy how you doing
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's going on ah well I've
reached a point of desperation in my
life I listen to you guys uh every night
but I still can't get my act together
um I have six kids uh and me and my wife
we maybe bring in about
65 000 a year we have no savings no
emergency fund and we're barely able to
pay our bills as they are
due to like a special circumstance or
I'm kind of getting double dipped for
child support where I'm paying for two
kids
who live with me
um
and
I'm I have two 600 car payments as well
as the student loans are getting ready
to drop we have about fifty thousand
forty thousand actually in student loans
between me and my wife what do you do
for a living man
I'm a bus driver for Disney
what do you make a year doing that
so I make about 55 000 a year uh and
that's with my overtime
and is your wife working outside the
home where's the other 10K coming from
um well my wife works over at Walmart
she's a regular associate okay and
that's part time
yes okay do you have a degree with these
student loans you got to pay back
I have a certificate from Universal
Technical Institute
and she has some schooling from Puerto
Rico
okay
well there's two pieces puzzle there's
decreasing expenses which you've got six
kids you've got a lot going on on top of
the debt payments on top of normal bills
that people have and then we've got to
also increase the income we've got to
find ways to make more because we've
we're in the situation where we have a
lot of mouths to feed and a lot of debt
to pay and do you hear George I want you
to George just distilled that down but
it's as simple as as that and I know
it's terrifying to think that it's that
simple but the only two options here are
to increase what you make and decrease
the expenses you have
so everything the only issue with that
is we've been looking uh and like but
you haven't because you got two 600 a
month car payments I would look right in
the driveway and I would go those things
got to go today yeah
what are the cars worth
my van's worth about 11 000 and we owe
14 in my Corolla is worth about 15 and
we owe I believe 13 but uh we needed the
Corolla because I live about 55 miles
from my job so I made the gas mileage
why is this the end-all be-all job
it's been very good to me it's I mean
you can't afford to live there brother I
mean you can't afford to work there it's
50 miles away
for fifty thousand dollars
you can go be an assistant manager at a
fast food restaurant and make that money
what is it about that job because that
job is costing you two hours of commute
time a day it's costing you a car you
cannot afford and it's not paying you
enough to pay your bills
yeah
I don't have I don't have a real good
answer for that I mean I I really enjoy
my job I enjoy the guests interaction oh
dude dude I know I'm I'm stomping on
your heart I know you love that job you
love the people and my understanding is
when you are fully bought in as a Disney
Employee it's it is it's a family big
time like it it's a community I get that
and you are broke and you can't breathe
and then you get in a car that's
depreciating every second you sit and
drive an hour in that traffic
to work a job that does not pay you
enough to support all six kids
what's your total Consumer Debt Jeremy
is your wife able to work more what does
the child care situation like I don't I
can't even imagine taking care of six
kids I imagine the ages are wildly
spread George has two
were they pugs yeah French Bulldogs
Bulldogs
okay 15.
I have it and my youngest two are two
and one okay
um so that's kind of where that comes
where she has to help uh with the babies
and well especially like while I'm while
I'm working and I mean it does yeah
that's one of the benefits one of the
benefits is that I do get to take my
kids to to Disney on my days off so I
mean that's kind of a benefit for my
children for the next couple of years
you don't get days off
you owe ninety thousand dollars
ninety thousand dollars you've got to
start making some Headway on this and I
do trust me I'm not trying to be a jerk
man I'm just trying to put both hands on
your shoulders and let you realize how
precarious your situation is
and if the cars can get us out of what
they can decrease our debt by twenty
seven thousand dollars obviously we've
got to save up some money we've got to
figure out the underwater situation
we've got to keep the keep the van right
keep the van because you got 14 000
children right so keep the van and then
I
here's what we're trying to do we're
trying to Rattle your cage a little bit
to get you out of the there's just no
way there is ways that you got to be
willing to go all in man
yeah if you called in he said hey I make
a hundred I got 50 to pay off we've got
all right let's make a plan but you're
making 65 and 0.90 and so the math is
skewed in a tough way where the only way
out of this is to go make a whole bunch
more money and do it quickly
and legally
and that means you're gonna have to work
several jobs that are not your dream job
do not fulfill your soul
that you're not going to ride home and
tell Mom about but that put money in
your account
yeah I've tried to look for like side
hustles or like different opportunities
uh Uber is just not a good one because
it just appreciates the value of the
asset
and Uber also I mean you could Uber to
work in home from work that is a thing
you could do
um stay on the line brother we're going
to give you FPU I'm going to send it to
you man and Financial Peace University
and the every dollar app I want you and
your wife to watch those videos man you
all have to get radical because you are
so close to the edge and George and I
spend our careers watching people fall
over the edge that don't want that to be
you
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show thank you for
joining us I'm George Campbell joined by
Dr John baloney if you like this show we
have a lots more where that came from in
fact my friend Dr John does his own show
called The Dr John baloney show right
next door in the studio over from us and
it's a wonderful wonderful show deeper
Dives deeper calls deeper everything
just a very deep show but also so fun
John brings a lot of levity to it I
don't know anyone's ever called it just
a wonderful show just a wonderful show
that's how that's how my grandmother
used to describe my haircuts like well
sometimes I'll walk by the studio while
you're doing it live and I go oh gosh
that's a doozy yeah they're heavy it's a
heavy show it's a lot of fun though you
handle it uh and you take it all in
stride and you help a lot of people and
it's I mean it's just exploded in
popularity so I appreciate it I'm now
trying to compete I've got my own
YouTube channel that is a lot dude I'm
salacious but we focus on making money
fun again I sang a cover of creed to
open a video about adjustable rate
mortgages if that tells you anything oh
I think this could not be about washed
up producer James played guitar in the
background and we had a good time with
that it's embarrassing for everybody
check out that video on adjustable rate
mortgages because that's what you want
to do on a Thursday there we go I
thought it was going to be something on
guilty pleasures hey um so I get this
question sometimes like uh hey we what
are you doing here right people ask me
like why do you why do you work here why
did Dave Ramsey hire you yes um and Dave
behind closed doors the joke is always
um I've been telling people for years
that money is 80 psychology and 20 like
knowledge right and he's also been
telling people for years you need to go
see somebody you go talk to somebody and
he finally just said I'm just gonna hire
my own right
there is some significant overlap when
it comes to finances in your mental
health and we know that I'm actually
working with a student
um a doctoral student with some
dissertation research on this and it I
can't tell you how much joy it brings me
to see these articles being written here
the article I'm holding right now
because it's bringing this to light and
we don't talk about it enough in our
culture if we look at anxiety we look at
depression we look at these things that
have a trend line almost
completely vertical they're going
straight up and they have been
if you lay a map or a a a graph on top
of that that plots the amount of money
individuals and we collectively owe in
this country it almost perfectly mimics
it wow I'm not saying it's causal but
there is correlation between debt and
your mental health so the article here
says comes as no surprise that debt
affects your mental health
new research shows that being in debt
not only increases anxiety
it also impacts your retirement plans
and marital status too we know those
things but people who have debt
report an increase in stress anxiety and
moodiness the national deep debt relief
noted that this can lead to divorce or
even putting off marriage three in five
Americans have considered putting off
marriage to avoid inheriting their
partner's debt we talked about marriage
and debt a segment ago and 54 believe
having a partner who's in debt is a
major reason to consider divorce
found that people lose over 200 hours of
sleep per year on average over their
debts now I just wanted to put that into
um
more Stark terms
the great Dr Matthew Walker has done
some extraordinary work and if you
haven't checked out his podcast or his
book why we sleep he should he's just a
master class and he's just so brilliant
and he speaks language that I could even
understand
talks about the catastrophic
consequences of a culture that stops
sleeping that goes simply from six hours
from seven hours a night to six hours
from eight hours to six and a half hours
it costs you everything cost you your
mental health it costs you long-term
Health short-term Health it disrupts
everything and so when people say yeah
I've got this debt over here but I'm
going to invest in the market or I just
have 50 000. yeah I just have my student
loans I say something like I have a
sleep tax that's the price I'm paying so
that I don't die with some of these
ailments losing sleep is killing us man
and this this surveys are showing the
the more debt you have the more sleep
you lose it says people aren't sleeping
they're having nightmares we're losing
about a month of sleep per year
wow and they're even talking about debt
nightmares yeah nightmares related to
the debt that you owe and this is even I
mean seven and ten said it feels like a
black cloud hangs over them when they
have to pay a bill or a loan 77 reported
debt would impact the retirement plans
they said they're missing out on more
activities turning down a night out with
friends they're turning down date nights
they're turning down attending weddings
and uh let's just that's life
that's life hanging out with your
friends celebrating weddings going to
weddings where you don't even know
anybody and you can dance even crazier
than you usually do right
um going out on dates even ones that are
awkward and weird this is life we are
cashing out our life
for this debt it's killing people man
it's not worth killing them it's killing
them it's killing them oh man this is
brutal and John you've been talking
about this at our Building Wealth events
that we were doing and every time you
say it the crowd just they're like yes
and here's what you say debt has a
physical weight on us and it's
scientific and you say hey how many of
you you've become debt free and you know
exactly what I'm talking about when that
weight gets lifted and they're all like
yes I remember that feeling and people
don't realize it's like wearing an ankle
bracelet holding you down you don't
realize it until they're off right how
much weight I remember I'm talking to
Dave this is I've been I've been
coasting the show with him for about six
months or so and I told him
um
I I didn't get nervous anymore right my
heart rate doesn't get up I'm not
nervous like oh gosh there's Millions
it's just it's just the job now
and I was going through some of the data
on my Smart Watch
like why is my heart rate spiking and
holding for like I wasn't exercising I
wasn't working
oh it reminded me of the great book
title by Dr Bessel vanderkolk the body
keeps the score I might not be feeling
anxious my body knows I'm talking to
millions of people and if I say one
thing wrong the whole company goes away
right it knows it knows and so you can
say Oh no I got a great deal man I don't
I got no APO I got no interest for five
years it's a good deal your body knows
dude if he says one thing wrong at work
they're going to take away the car
they're gonna take away his job they're
gonna take away his marriage
this is not safe right your body knows
and there's that feeling everybody who
gets on the debt free stage says when
you ask him how does it feel their whole
you can go back and just watch their
whole body changes completely they
exhale they drop their shoulders it's
freedom from uh uh a cage you didn't
even know you were locked in right so
debt does affect your mental health I
would go as far to say and I don't have
the the Huber menesque
huberman-esque uh you know neuro studies
to backnia but I don't believe a person
can be fully unanxious can have a life
that is not stressed chronically
stressed
unless you don't owe anybody anything
there's some peace there where your body
goes we are safe now that car is ours
that house is ours that land is ours and
we get to decide what we do tomorrow not
the bank and anything other than that
has some sort of physiological
consequence to it man I just believe
that well Dave's been saying for years
that we want you we want you to have
nice stuff we don't want nice stuff to
have you right and now there's actually
research to back up what he was saying
and it's not just a payment holding you
back financially it's the payment
affecting your mental health it affects
your heart rate affects the ability for
you to sleep it affects your
conversations with your spouse it
affects you will being willing to go in
there and dig a Little Deeper to save
that marriage or dude I'm just gonna
bail right it's just it's a black cloud
I love the way they say that it's just a
storm cloud there's clear research that
that lack of sleep will shorten your
lifespan oh dude the data is too clear
on that and so for that reason alone get
out of debt I mean I don't know what
more data we need to give you to say
here's a good reason to get not because
Dave Ramsey said so because I want you
to live to meet your grandkids right I
think that's a noble goal to have and so
do whatever it takes this article of
course has a terrible solution consider
debt relief options yeah the survey was
put out by national debt relief you
think they didn't pay for this uh so
here's a better option you pay off your
debt you are the secret sauce we believe
this crazy belief that you can pay the
debt that you got yourself into you're
the problem you're the solution and that
is so freeing when you let it not
control you and not put the shame and
guilt and all that Let It Go and say the
guy in the mirror is the solution to my
problems I don't have to wait on a
politician I don't have to wait on a
debt relief company I can do this so go
through Financial Peace University use
the every dollar app connect with other
people on the journey do whatever it
takes because debt Freedom's on the
other side and you will sleep better and
you will live longer and uh I think
that's a life well spent John hey I love
making up science on the air I love it
it's what we do that's what we do this
is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney this is the Ramsay show the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Clinton joins us
up next in Springfield Clinton welcome
to the show how you doing
hi thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help okay I have a little bit of
analysis analysis paralysis and I was
wondering if you guys could get some
input on it
um so I have about thirty thousand
dollars combined in Consumer Debt it's a
auto loan and a student loan
um my employer offers 200 a month
towards my student loans as long as I
maintain a minimum payment
and I was wondering if I should do a
minimum payment on my student loans
which is a higher balance
and then pay off my car loan first or if
I should just stay with the baby steps
and pay off the smaller incremental
loans uh from the student loans first
so what is the car loan balance
about twelve thousand okay and then what
is your smallest student loan balance uh
the smallest one's like 100 bucks but
the normal ones are like 2 000.
okay so what what's wrong with following
the debt snowball method and just paying
them off smallest to largest would that
affect this
no I just think that 200 incentive was
giving me wiggle room for some reason
and I was just kind of curious so you
would lose the 200 a month
as long as I make minimum payments on
the student loans we keep the 200 a
month but if you make more than that
then you lose it
nope they they keep doing it as well oh
so I don't see the issue then am I not
tracking John
yeah I don't really understand what
you're saying so I think you can't you
have to like turn over your bank
statement every month
no I just have to make the payments in
like as long as they see I'm making the
payments they'll pay me the 200 towards
my account how do they know how does
your boss know what you're paying in
your personal banking
uh I haven't done so it doesn't start
until payments resume
um from what I remember they just have
to you can like hook them up with your
uh uh student loan servicer
yeah I would I would never
let my boss have access to my private
banking's information or my bills ever
I wouldn't take the 200 on that
principal alone that's pure principle
and that's just me that's not speaking
for Ramsey that's just me now if you can
submit you know a PDF verifying the
amount that's definitely do that but I'm
still confused if you just do the debt
snowball and you attack the smallest
student loan First You're Gonna knock it
out quick they're going to give you an
extra 200 bucks to do that what's the
problem just following this through it
looks like they would just only amp up
your payoff process
yeah you're right and like I said I was
just kind of getting hung up on the
question and I just wanted some more
input really
I would just it's basically just gravy
it's icing on the cake to get the extra
200 bucks from your employer but I'm
living my life and following the debt
snowball and you're going to attack this
fast if you do that because you got 30k
total what's the car worth
uh about 18. okay and what's your income
uh about 59. okay cool are you single
married
uh we got engaged on the second one oh
nice congratulations
that is awesome
yeah so that I mean that solves that in
my book and that hopefully solves your
analysis paralysis I'm just following
the debt snowball and break the student
loans out don't look at it as one big
balance break them out because they're
probably a bunch of separate little
debts and just start attacking them with
event of vengeance
okay yeah that makes sense thank you you
got it appreciate the call Clinton
Madeline is up next in Baltimore
Maryland welcome to the show
hi can you hear me yeah what's going on
thank you for taking my call
um sorry I'm a little nervous it's just
doctor
thank you um I started listening
um in 2017 I was fresh out of college I
had thirty thousand dollars in student
loans and a five thousand dollar
personal loan and I started getting this
guy who's now my husband and he
encouraged me to listen to the Ramsey
Show and I was able to pay off my loans
in three years as a teacher awesome huge
blessing yeah and you married well
I did yeah so now we're in a great
situation
um we're debt free we got married last
year
um this kind of starts my context for my
question so when we decided to get
married my parents
um kind of offered to pay for our
wedding my parents have a high income
but my husband encouraged me to think a
little bit more about it because my dad
had paid for the majority of my private
college and it comes up a lot in a
negative way he kind of will say
he'll he'll bring up a lot that he did
that and so he said he didn't want that
hangover heads with our wedding and so
we decided to pay for the whole wedding
by ourselves and we did it without that
and we were able to purchase a home now
a year later with 20 down Wow way to go
your husband's amazing your husband's
incredible a lot of wisdom
yeah and it's all my husband I'm really
thankful for him
um so we're in a really great situation
really showing it financially but like I
alluded my family has some just kind of
like emotional problems like my parents
and my siblings my dad has been addicted
to alcohol since the beginning of the
pandemic and it's the worst it just gets
worse and worse and he's pretty
unrecognizable and then actually in
December he was diagnosed with stage
four cancer
um
and so my family is in a really bad
position
um somewhat financially but a lot just
relationally and my husband and I he's
been really supportive but we're trying
to figure out and this kind of raises my
question I would just love y'all's
thoughts on just like biblically and and
faith-wise
um what our responsibility is to our
parents and families because I want to
be a good daughter but it just gets
messy when they're not living on the
same values that we are
yeah that's tough
um George I'll throw my two cents in
there and you throw yours in there
um so here's here's kind of like my my
thoughts and again when you interview
talking about obligations and
spirituality and religion it it it just
is a firestorm right uh if you're right
you're wrong all that kind of stuff
right so this is just this is just me as
for me in my house okay
um I do believe that I've got a
responsibility to honor my father mother
I do believe I have a responsibility to
take care of my household and I think in
America we tend to look at household as
my kids but I think at some point if my
parents move in with me or become
Indigent and have to then I do feel like
I've got some some sort of
responsibility there here's where that
gets sticky in our current world
most of the time I hear the question
you're asking one of two things is true
number one my the family is not asking
for your help in any way
and you're watching somebody or a group
of people you love literally kill
themselves with their alcohol challenges
or their
um struggles with addiction or whatever
else is how they're spending their money
Etc and it's tough when you're watching
your parents with health issues or
financial issues or whatever and they
couldn't give two box of farts about
what you think about that because they
didn't ask you
and so that's usually number one
the other one number two is
you want to help but they want that help
on their terms
meaning they have a million dollar house
and they're telling you they're broke
and need help paying for stuff and you
say I'll help but you got to get out of
the house it's condo time because you
don't have any money and they're like no
this is our family house we've had this
house for 30 years this is our family
house and so that's where I think it's
not your responsibility I can find I
don't have any sort of scriptural or
religious or biblical mandate to say
your job is to prop up their lifestyle
whatever that looks like you're their
Bank
but I do think sitting down with your
husband and saying okay what would help
look like
what would care look like is it giving
them information is it giving them
Financial Peace University is it
providing them with 500 a month and
you're going to help pay their bill like
what does help look like for you
and then go sit down with them and say
all right here's what we're able and
willing to do in this season and when
you're ready to talk about your
struggles of alcohol we're here if
you're ready to go to rehab we're here
if you are ready to sell the house we're
here
but at some level that's the best you
could do does that make sense yeah if
that does make a lot of sense okay so
sorry going through this don't
overextend yourself talk with your
husband about what you're willing to do
what you're willing to commit to and it
says honor your father and mother
doesn't say enable and so do what you're
comfortable with and uh I mean this is a
tough situation may just be more
supporting the family emotionally being
there for them and part of that may be
Financial wow sorry to hear work with
your husband every step of the way as
you'll as you'll decide what you're
going to do together
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
grateful you're here wherever you're
listening we're in so many places now
Spotify YouTube Radio you can watch us
on TBN and just to add another option
for you guys we are now streaming on
Twitter so if you want to watch the
Ramsay show on Twitter it's a very
similar feed to what you would get on
YouTube and you can catch it on Twitter
streaming starting at 3 pm
that's central Time Monday through
Friday I think it's central time they
didn't write the time zone for me but
I'm just going to make a wild assumption
so 3 P.M Monday through Friday you can
catch us on Twitter just go to at
ramsayshow or twitter.com Ramsay show
hit the follow button there get some
notifications and we will let you know
when we are streaming the show over
there just one more you know why not
Twitter's going big on video now we got
we got the new threads app from
Instagram John and I are just trying to
keep up it's exhausting guys do we need
another platform no
but they gave it to us fewer platforms
but John is on there you can follow him
on threads I don't even know how to find
him for reading it up he's threading it
up there we go John wasn't on social
media three years ago and now he's
obsessed I'm a guru wow all right hey
more of your calls are coming up AAA
825-5225 Austin joins us up next in
Fayetteville Arkansas good place what's
going on Austin
hey y'all thank you for taking my call
um hey so my main question is should I
convince my wife to get a job to help
pay our mortgage
um and I've got a little bit of a back
story here I'll try to keep it short and
sweet basically
um my parents have some land
um not very far from where I work I got
married four years ago I've got two kids
um and I'm 24 years old I'm debt free
um but we entered into an agreement with
my parents that they would gift us some
land if we built a house on it and then
that would be our piece of land
we would just have to pay for the house
so I built the house myself ended up
saving about a little over 50 percent of
what it would have cost to buy one new
um and like I did all the Electrical
Plumbing all that stuff myself wow um
and uh so it's been a learning
experience a lot of YouTube
um but now I've kind of got myself in a
hole where
um the the house is more expensive than
I initially thought it was going to be
we kind of shop for 175 thousand dollars
it's going to be closer to that two
hundred thousand dollars we also were
planning to build
two years ago when the interest rates
were 2.5 percent now they're seven
percent
um and it's about time to buy the house
we've almost finished it and uh you know
my wife's a stay-at-home mom uh she
takes care of our two kids uh daycare in
our area is about 800 a kid a month
um and I just don't know if it's worth
it to
um convince her to get
um a job to help pay for the mortgage
well if you can figure out how to
convince a wife that's I mean you need
to be hosting the show man I don't know
that I can convince my wife I think
that's the title of your first book and
it's called so I convinced my wife dot
dot dot yeah that's a tough situation
what I would do is just start the
conversation and say hey here's some
options because I I know you're feeling
this too financially we're in a bind
here and part of it is owning hey this
is my fault
I got us into this I had this idea that
I was going to do this and it was going
to be this much and I didn't do great
math and it's put our family in a tough
situation or the world changed
underneath us while we were doing it and
mortgage interest rates are now triple
what they were and so we need a solution
here one of the solutions is for you to
work so that we can provide more income
and it'll be more than we would be
spending on daycare or we'd have to put
the kids in daycare so you'd have to
bring in at least 1600 bucks take-home
pay to make this worth it and that would
allow us to cover this what do you think
about it
gotcha yeah that makes sense it's just
more of a question that I'm struggling
with should I try to convince her
um rather than do I have to
um and so I I know that we can make it
work
um it is High I mean we're looking at
probably 35 percent uh of take-home pay
uh to the mortgage which I know is is
really tough and I know that I'd like to
keep it to that 25 but but it's kind of
this I you know I screwed up you know
and I'm kind of in this situation now
and what's your income but you know uh
so I I'm at about 62 000. well can I
tell you how old are you again
24.
can I tell you something that will
change your entire life
if you learn this at 24 what it took me
to learn into my 40s
I'm gonna give you two decades of your
of your life and your marriage back
and you're going to become a pillar in
your community and you're going to
become the husband that your wife has
always dreamed you could be
and I know that's quite a setup are you
in
I'm in
I want you to sit down and tell her
exactly what you just told me in George
honey I saw a dream in front of us and
my parents made us a good deal
and I went for this and I missed and I'm
scared to death
and here's a couple of options I would
love it if you would sit down and dream
with me on and come together because I'm
carrying a lot of shame because I feel
like we had agreement that we're gonna
do this 25 thing the world spun
underneath us I kept building this thing
ballooned on me in price and cost and
now I'm scared to death and I can't
breathe and I'm sorry
and what you're going to give her is the
gift not of weakness and cowardly
nonsense you're giving her vulnerability
you're giving her honesty and integrity
and you're letting her in
on the guy she married
which is just something that doesn't
happen
and man give her an opportunity to speak
into what happens next and from that
place at that breakfast or that lunch
y'all are having then you can sit down
and say okay if you get a job sixteen
hundred dollars off the top goes to take
care of our kids
what job can you make 3 500 bucks a
month or four thousand bucks a month and
how long would you have to do that like
be real specific on how long we would do
this come up with a plan and also say or
it's just going to be tight for a few
years and then we're going to refinance
when the interest rates go down but if
you start with that
you don't need to convince her of
anything you need to sit down and say
here's what I did and here's how I feel
about it and will you work with me on on
digging out
see I see the difference there one is
I'm right and I gotta get her into this
place the other is coming with hands
wide open saying I screwed this thing up
and I love you so much and will you work
with me I'm making this right
yeah absolutely yeah that that's awesome
I would even write it down because it's
going to be weird and hard to do I'd
write it down and read that letter
that's very romantic too it's not very
romantic at all actually I don't know
maybe it's romantic I don't know
um I think a handwritten letter is very
nice I mean you don't want to hand it to
her
no you just read it out loud say I wrote
this it's that important to me George
George would text this by the way he
would just text it Snapchat it honey I
messed up LOL
Shake It Off emojis emojis yeah exactly
yeah I think it's more about reframing
this I need to convince her to we have
to come up with some options yeah and
I'm gonna I'm gonna go first hey let me
ask you one quick question Austin when
you your folks gave you this land did
they
did they deed it over to you do you have
a copy of this is my land and I've got
the paperwork and they've got it they've
got it sectioned off and everything with
the county
um they do have it sectioned off but
it's not in my name yet
um when I purchased the house they were
going to deed it over to me
okay I would not rest until that's done
because unfortunately George and I've
done the show long enough that people
come into agreements with their parents
and they build a house and then dad's
like oh I'll get to it I'll get to it
and then dad passes away or dad leaves
or dad changes his mind or dad gets laid
off and he needs the land for something
else and then he charges you for it or
you see what I'm saying it just gets
messy and I know that probably isn't
your parents but man it's good to have
everything nice and clean yeah a lot of
the calls in the show are my parents did
this and it was a family agreement and
then it all went sideways and so we're
just looking ahead for you the other
option Austin is what if you could make
up the Gap with your income whether
that's increasing your job full time or
getting a side job to make up that 10
Gap and take home pay
yeah yeah that that's a good option too
yeah and again I don't know that's an
option when you're sitting down with
your wife saying here's an option you go
back to work you'd have to make a bunch
of money or here's another option I'm
going to take a second job until at
least I can get us up to this much of a
down payment so that we can avoid X Y
and Z all those things are are on the
table when you sit down and say will you
join me in this new adventure yeah I'll
take options over ultimatums any day I
think the conversation's gonna go a
whole lot better versus I got to
convince you to do this and if you don't
we're screwed so thanks for the call man
wishing you guys the best through this
Home Building Journey that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsesolutions.com
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramsesolutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by my good friend Dr
John baloney and we are pumped to take
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you need a
little help a little advice to take the
right next step with your life your
money your relationships your mental
health whatever it is we want to attempt
to do that for you today Daniel kicks us
off in San Jose Daniel welcome to the
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
sure how can we help
yeah so I'm a worship and media director
at a local church here and my wife and I
are expecting our first child congrats
thank you yeah she has had some
complications and we've experienced some
pretty big Financial hits this year so
she is out of work until she's due so my
question is I'm definitely called into
the ministry however with these
Financial hits
um is it worth us uh was it worth myself
going and looking for another job
um and leaving the ministry looking for
part-time
uh we just uh we really don't know
uh what steps to take especially when
they feel called into Ministry when you
when you say I feel called what does
that mean
I believe the Lord has has designed me
to be a worshiper and a worship leader
okay and that's that's my role at the
church is to lead people into worship
and communion with him okay what about
um what you're calling at home how would
you describe that
a husband and soon to be father and
provider for the home okay so at some
level if we distill it all the way down
there's there's a conflict between those
two callings that you feel right
yep so what I would suggest is this
um if I was to label a call that I had
in my life
I would say it's to help people
have a little bit better day after
they've interacted with me than before
and when I was younger I attached a call
to a job to a title
and I started realizing that Ministry
has done
outside of a church just as well as it's
done and as much as it's done inside of
a church in fact they're they're it's
everywhere it's how I treat the waitress
it's how I honor my wife and my kids
it's how I take care of my friend George
when he screws something up it's it's a
way of being
and so my challenge for you would be a
ask yourself and this is for you and
your theological
um mind to sit down and work through
is God calling you
to a job
over
taking care of your wife and kids in
this season because the money you're
making at this job is not paying your
bills
correct or can you be a person
who brings people closer together
who connects people whether you work at
Burger King or whether you work on a
stage at a church or whether you work
changing tires at a local whatever or
you're a a counselor
can your call expand to I'm a person who
brings people together
that's what I do and if I somebody hands
me a guitar and puts me on a stage
that's what I do it if somebody you know
hands me a wrench I'm going to turn it
I'm gonna make sure that guy and his
family have a safe car to go on their
vacation I'm gonna bring that family
together you see what I'm saying
yeah and so when I started looking for
my quote-unquote call which is a whole
other conversation George that I think
we in our culture just got sideways
um I went looking for a job description
and podcasting and YouTube did not exist
it wasn't it didn't it wasn't hadn't
been invented yet and so I've learned
that here's what I really think I'm good
at and here's what I think um
um have
I spent 25 years trying to be good at
this thing like learning the craft and
this thing whether it's on the radio
whether Dave fires me tomorrow and I go
do it in in a counseling office or I go
back to be a professor whatever it is
I just am going to continue to want
people to be a little more peaceful
after they meet with me right I think
that the idea of call expands much
Beyond job description right yeah but
yeah it's a hard it's a hard hard
decision I'd also think this man
if you choose to step away for a season
hey it's not forever and B grieve it
you're gonna miss it you get to play
music every week right you get to write
music and sit with hurting people like
that that's something that you love to
do right
yeah
So tactically Daniel I see there's a few
options here number one I think we need
to go to church leadership and tell them
honestly your situation
not with any expectation but just to let
them know here hey here's what's going
on I don't want to leave this place but
right now I need to go pay some bills
and I'm looking into some part-time jobs
and that's option one is that you work
there full time and you take on a
part-time job which could affect you
know your family because you're gone and
your wife is going through it right now
or you leave the ministry maybe you do
that part-time as a volunteer at the
church and you work full-time in a
different role right now until you guys
get some Financial stability and then
maybe one day the role opens back up or
it's still there and you go back to
doing what you love
that's how I see it I always like to
give myself options even if I don't love
all of them
yeah that's good and I'll also pass this
along again I I I'll I'm sure I'll get
people an earful of other people's
theology but
um I had a mentor of mine one time I was
I was young I was young I was in my 20s
and I was back and forth and trying to
find what God was asking me to do here
and here and here and that's all over
the place and he said something that was
pretty transformative for me and he said
has it ever occurred to you that maybe
God doesn't care what you do
he just cares who you are on the way it
is to wherever it is you're going
and that was a significant shift for me
because I think of the people all over
the Earth who are in hellacious
situations
um and ask myself are they being called
to a three-car garage are they being
called to be a person of honor and
integrity and uphold their whatever
their religious values are in the face
of great oppression in the face of in
the face of great fear in the face of
God knows what right and so this idea of
call becomes a much more expansive thing
than
um yeah
I have to work at this building at this
job
that's just my thoughts man I can be way
out to lunch one man's opinion there's
people pulling over screaming and
yelling All Over America right now that
guy's an idiot heretic but how does that
sit with you man
that's great what are you leaning
towards that's great that's great thanks
guys if you we hang up what are you
gonna go do
you know I actually uh have a meeting
plan to talk to our leadership
um
but I I do feel that we need to we need
to get some more income coming in cool
do you have another option like if you
had to go get a new job tomorrow what
would it be
you know I don't have uh I don't really
have that lined up but I'm willing to go
flip Burgers if that's what it means I
knew you would hang on the line I'm
going to send you um my my buddy Ken
Coleman his get clear assessment that
can give you some options to say okay
here's what I'm really good at here's
what I love doing here's what I think
I've been called to do
and here are a million different places
where I might be able to do those very
things that I've never even thought of
hang on the line here we'll get it sent
over to you on on us blessings to you
brother congratulations on this new baby
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
I'm George Campbell he's Dr John deloney
this is the Ramsey Show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
well John a piece of news crossed our
desk and we are not a men of the news
but we report news that I think is
eye-opening to our viewers and listeners
and helps them make good choices with
their money which is why I share this
article from
consumerfinance.gov cfpb takes action
against Bank of America for a legally
charging junk fees withholding credit
card rewards and opening fake accounts
and the cfpb which is the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau if you're
not in with the cool kids they ordered
Bank of America to pay more than a
hundred million dollars to customers for
systematically double dipping on fees
imposed on them with insufficient funds
in their account withholding those
reward bonuses which they were promised
to and misappropriating sensitive
personal information in order to open
accounts without the customer's
authorization or knowledge wow
this is dark stuff I mean this is some
Wells Fargo level stuff and I you know
it doesn't surprise me that's from Bank
of America which is probably the next
worst bank out there but you said that
so dramatically it's Wells Fargo Wells
Fargo
like they're like oh my gosh this is sad
I I think until the banking industry
decides to align incentives across the
board right and what I mean by that is
we're talking about rough air
if
person X has an incentive and they have
no skin in the game down the road
they're going to do whatever they can to
meet their incentive in their local
market right and
on and on and on it goes down the road
until you get an entire culture where
cutting Corners making numbers for the
end of the the quarterly returns
just becomes a huge mess oh man this is
wild so to unfully understand what
happened there it goes yeah sales to
meet to meet now schools so here's
here's how to explain this so you have a
local teller who is told if you get this
many open accounts then you get a bonus
that person doesn't have to deal with
any of the accounts doesn't manage the
account that's my job I will get you 10.
and then it gets to the end of the month
and somebody comes in and opens a
checking account and there's no skin off
anybody's nose if he goes ahead and just
opens a savings account and a money
market account as well and I get to book
three I got three well then let's say
that savings account has a minimum and
then this person gets a a bill right for
ten dollars because you didn't have the
minimum of an account you didn't open
and then the next teller opens it and
goes well you opened it on this date and
it just snowballs that way right and
that person gets his gets his thing then
the person collecting overdraft fees
gets theirs and it rolls all the way up
it's the same as back in the mortgage
the the mortgage-backed Securities issue
the bank who made the loan to that
mortgage didn't have to hold the payoff
they sold it right away so they had no
one they the only incentive was to make
the loan not can this guy actually pay
this loan back someday I don't care
about that I'm selling the sucker I just
need to make the loan today and if you
keep passing the buck passing the buck
and everybody doesn't have skin in the
game you get these big huge collapses
the whole thing Falls over man or you
get big systematic cultural schemes like
this kind of nonsense man that's pretty
wild that the employees illegally
applied for and enrolled consumers and
credit card accounts without their
knowledge or authorization they in some
cases illegally use or obtain Consumers
Credit reports without their permission
to complete applications so they can
customer hadn't even completed the
application like you have an account now
here's your line of credit
goodness gracious that's frightening and
this is not the first time
uh they've got a little slap on the
wrist to the tune of a few million in
2014 the cfpb ordered Bank of America to
pay 727 million dollars in redress to
its victims for a legal credit card
practices
in May of 2022 they had to pay 10
million in the Civil penalty over
unlawful garnishments and later in 2022
because they didn't learn their lesson
another 225 million that and required it
to pay hundreds of millions in dollars
in redress to Consumers for botched
disbursement of state of unemployment
benefits at the height of kova 19. well
and it makes me think this the bank has
uh as of March 31st to 2.4 trillion
dollars in Consolidated assets and 1.9
trillion dollars in domestic deposits
right so that's a four
four and a half ish trillion dollar bank
so these fines you're like 700 million
dollars like cool where do I say where
do I send the check right
um and that's that again these little
slap on the wrists 100 million dollars
which sounds like the end of time for
you and me is like okay that's the price
of doing business when you're making
four trillion dollars yeah so the lesson
learned here number one don't do
business with Wells Fargo or Bank of
America or any of these big scummy
companies uh we love local Community
Banks Credit Unions that's a great place
to do your banking locally and another
piece of this is don't play with debt
because they are snakes and they will
get you and I have a healthy distrust of
banks because their name is stamped all
over stadiums and the biggest buildings
downtown and your name isn't and that
tells me they're winning so when they're
marketing to you with all these sweet
commercials and there's like smiling
families and they're telling you how
they can get you a great deal on a loan
run away
it is a horror movie waiting to happen
I don't know any other advice there John
when it comes to banking this is just
it's just sad and we've been talking
we've been talking trash about these
folks for years now no it's just until
until
but switching your bank is so much more
people are like it's too much work it's
worth the work to get out from under
these guys this this just reminds me of
you know the the industry that I love
higher ed until people get serious about
making it right it's going to continue
to
help some people and really hurt other
people and it's just gonna man it's
really saves me I wish we could just get
in there and solve the problem before it
becomes so catastrophic that you have to
rebuild some out of Ash yeah it doesn't
have to be that way but here we are
there we go all right let's go to the
phones Michael's up next in Huntsville
Alabama Michael welcome to the show
hey guys how's it going thanks for
taking my call sure what's going on with
you
hey well um I'll get to try to get
straight to my point uh a lot came
available in a neighborhood that my wife
and I uh is highly desirable for us and
we're trying to figure out if we want to
sell our our current residence our house
and uh start a construction loan and
temporarily move into an apartment while
the house is being built and then uh
once the house is built uh just have the
primary mortgage on the new property and
the new uh new lot
okay sounds reasonable so far do you
guys have the money to do all this
well we would we would definitely have
to sell our
start the the construction loan
because that's a big move but what would
the net profit be if you sold the house
what would you get after fees and paying
off the mortgage we would probably get
around 200 000 out of my house in net
profit we could sell it for about 300
and we we owe about 80 on it right now
cool so you have 200 to put down what
would that mean for your construction
loan and the primary mortgage later on
oh the primary mortgage later on we're
looking around probably uh uh probably
around a four hundred thousand dollar
house
um give or take you know we have to buy
the lot the lot's about 90 000 uh so
you're talking about
yes about about five hundred thousand
and give or take in total yes okay and
you have 200 of that
yes we have 200 of that so that would
leave you with about a 300 000 mortgage
once this is all said and done
yep about a three hundred thousand
dollar mortgage uh once we get
everything finalized after we've stayed
an apartment for uh I guess a year or so
and what's your income
uh our income right now uh gross is
about 170 000. 165 great income
okay so what is your concern in all of
this
well we're just concerned with the
market you know with the the interest
rates and how how high it was uh is
we're we tried to buy a house about a
year ago and and it kind of fell through
because we were just kind of nervous
about uh getting out and selling our
house and then getting a higher interest
rate uh with the way the Market's going
because we we bought our house in 2019
right before all the craziness happened
and we're just kind of scared to I guess
jump off into the deep end you know what
I mean yeah I mean I don't want you to
make this huge decision based off of the
interest rate being higher or lower I
want you to make the decision because
you're ready for it financially and it's
what you guys really want to do
okay so I would jump on to our mortgage
calculator ramseysolutions.com you're
probably looking at I want you to do a
15-year fix where the payments no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay I
think you guys can get there with this
income if that's stable and this could
be a great move for you it's obviously a
lot of work you're going to sell the
thing you got to go rent it's going to
take more time than you think it's going
to be more expensive than you think but
it doesn't sound unreasonable John did I
miss anything
all right we did it we solved at least
one problem today right here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John baloney we
are grateful you are joining us right
now and if you're enjoying the show I
would ask you to do one thing it's a
free show what I'm asking you to do is
completely free and it's easy it's quick
and that is to share the show please
consider subscribing hit the follow
button wherever you're hanging out with
us leave a review and especially share
this with people in your life that you
love people that you want to see win in
every area whether that's money
relationships mental health or career
that's what this show is all about and
uh I was talking to a fan that was out
there visiting John he was like I don't
watch the news anymore I just watched
the Ramsay show and my life is just
better because there's no question about
that we don't do a lot of uh if it
bleeds it leads kind of headlines around
here the callers call in with their
questions and we just have plenty of
Blood on the show as is yeah we don't
need any more of that and so we
appreciate all of you who have shared
this with people and you never know what
impact you're gonna have that one
episode could spark something in their
life to where transformation happens and
we're grateful for all of that so thank
you thank you thank you
let's go to Austin in Dallas up next
Austin welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's going on
yeah so um I just I don't know if it's
pretty simple or not but
um I have a mortgage uh it started it
was a 382 000 property and I put 20 down
um so there's about 300 left on the
mortgage and I have a family member that
could help me pay off that mortgage
and so I was trying to figure out if
that's a good idea or not and if that
would be the best use of their money but
if so what would be like a the best Fair
way to go about doing that
that was that was the Vegas way you
could have described that be a little
more specific yeah what was this
conversation like did they bring this up
did you bring it up is this a gift is it
your dad is it some weird cousin that's
gonna expect stuff tell us more
uh no it would be uh my one of my
parents my mom and you know just
collectively my parents and then they
would she just my mom has some savings
and she's looking to do something with
that savings but she's not quite sure uh
she must come from different households
because some savings and she has an
extra 300 Grand laying around is a very
different scenario that's amazing she's
done very well
uh yeah she's put in a lot of work over
a long period of time is this a large
part of her world and her is this
retirement where is the savings coming
from and what would she use it on
instead of this
I'm not quite sure what it would be a
significant portion of her you know
total wealth right
um
but at least I mean somewhere I'm not
quite sure how did this come up man
she and I were just talking about it and
she knows that I have a mortgage I just
got the house not too long ago and she
would use her funds to
either purchase another rental property
um purchase a home or a property and you
know try to
have her money grow that way
here's why I don't like this
I don't like it because you don't have
peace in your spirit about it
there's something about this that is
giving you pause whether you're
wondering if mom actually has this money
whether sometimes parents give gifts and
it's their way of putting hooks deeper
in their kids
or
um you don't want to be responsible for
something down the road I don't know
what it is but you don't have peace in
your spirit about this I got no problem
with parents who want to surprise their
kids and pay off their house I think
that's amazing I would love to be in
that financial position to do that for
my kids someday
um
but that doesn't sound like the case
here
it would be just more is that the best
use of her money you don't you don't
like this sounds weird I don't think you
get a vote in how she uses her money
right
um and truthfully the better use of the
money for her without you being involved
is she goes and invests this money in a
mutual fund and it becomes her
retirement plan so I don't think it's
about is this the best use if this is
just a gift out of her heart and she
says I have this money it's not going to
affect my retirement my it's not going
to affect my financial world I just want
to bless you with it that's amazing but
I don't know that that's the case here
and that's the piece that gives us pause
right well I think that you know I would
I would be treated at the very least as
like a gift so I'd want to return that
to her over a period of time see that's
what worries me
again this is a big old loan that she
wants an Roi on just say no thank you
Mom I love you too much I'd walk away
yeah or it's hey remember that time I
paid off your mortgage now take care of
me for the rest of my life because I
don't have any retirement well it went
broke the way you just said that put the
puzzle piece together for me it sounds
like she's gonna go get a rental
property and expect cash back
or she's going to pay your mortgage off
and instead of you paying your mortgage
to the mortgage company you're going to
pay Mom right or when you sell it she
goes okay I'd like my 300 now because I
kind of need it I'd love to get a rental
property with it and you go whoa I
thought that was my money because it was
a gift
so I think I'd be totally fine with that
though because I think that that would
be fair right like you don't know what
the future holds no because then it's
just a big long loan
it's just a loan with no interest
right and that's where the question like
what is the best and most Fair way to
handle it would be but not handling at
all might be the solution I I I'm
assuming what I would do in my house I
would say thank you so much for the
offer it means the world to me
um I want to be all grown up and so I'm
going to go through the process and do
this myself
and if I've got total peace in my spirit
about something then I'm all in but you
don't have that I don't have that for
you and it sounds like there's going to
be some strings attached to this that's
just going to muddy the relationship
between a father I mean a son and his
mother and man let's keep that as as
pure as possible it's one of the most
important relationships you'll ever have
well said retweet thanks for the call
Austin Zach is up next in Kansas City
Zach welcome to the Ramsay show
hey George and John thanks for taking my
call yeah what's up man
well uh we're new to Financial Peace
University my wife and I we just started
our classes this week awesome um we've
got our budget plan in place and all
that uh we've got a two-year-old son and
a daughter on the way
um we're exiting the Army pretty soon
after seven years and traveling back to
St Louis to be a part of a family
business and we have other
entrepreneurships we do as well but um
we have the option to live with my
in-laws until we find a house or take on
a mortgage
but I'd like to try and pay cash for a
piece of property and then build or pay
for it as we go and as we can afford it
currently we don't have any debt and
almost 50 Grand in the bank
um but it's going to put some stress on
my in-laws I'm sure they love us and
their grandkids and they're willing to
house us until we're ready to move
somewhere and with the current housing
situation I'm hesitant to buy a home I
just want to see what y'all thought of
it so did they invite you or did you ask
them hey we're exiting the military
would you guys be cool with us living
with with you for a while
yeah we had a family sit-down discussion
and
um it it you know as a as a father and a
provider for my family it's it's kind of
hard for me to be willing to to live
with someone in like I should be able to
provide right I should be able to afford
to home you know my family and stuff so
it's kind of
I'd like to be able to just go and buy a
house but I'm I'm I don't want to take
on a mortgage if I don't have to and
then I can potentially set us up for
real financial success you know but
they're if you're still married
if you're still married after living
with your in-laws and your little kids
based on how you said this it's going to
put stress on them you've got another
little baby on the way this is going to
be chaos and so I would you're not
throwing away money by renting for a
year as you continue to save up a down
payment and if you want to pay cash
that's great I wouldn't sit on the
sidelines for the next 10 years as you
wait to say a save up cash so if you can
do this quickly that's a plan but
otherwise I'd wait till you can afford a
15-year fixed rate where the payment's
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay and let me say I'll even go one step
further George
if this is you saying no just because of
your egos act I'm a provider and I'm a
man and you haven't you have an
opportunity to fast forward the
financial future of your life of your
family's life significantly by just
sucking it up for six months and you and
your wife and your mother-in-law and
your father-in-law sit down and draw up
some things in writing
I don't have a problem with it I have a
problem with it if you're going to be
moping around and the whole time there's
no end date on this thing and it just
turns into four months turns into eight
months turns into a year it turns into
it never ends right so if there's some
clarity there and it's just your ego I
don't have a super big problem with it
but I'm with George man it sounds like
the right move is to go rent a place a
tiny little place that y'all can suck it
up and and manage it until y'all can get
that house yeah I've just rarely had
people call in and say we live with our
in-laws for a year and it was just
amazing and it was the best thing ever
it's always like we live with our
in-laws because we tried to save money
so tread with caution thanks this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
27 1. do not boast about tomorrow for
you do not know what a day may bring
Martin Short once said if you have
wonderful moments don't second-guess
them just enjoy them
I like that just be present John have
you ever tried that for once I love
Martin Short good guy good I don't I'm
not friends with them I don't know him
but I'd love to be Martin if you're
listening appreciate that open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Tyler's up next in Jackson
Mississippi Tyler what's going on
hey uh no I was trying to call because
um I'm young and I've kind of gotten it
as bad I guess inning was just being
money and I make a lot about it I didn't
really grow up making a lot and I was
just trying to see what all you know
give me advice on
um I work for the railroad uh I started
at I mean I turned 19 right when I
started in in the industry
um I make around 123 000 a year that's
not including overtime or any of the
benefits paid
um and I don't have any debt other than
one car I recently bought about a year
ago and that was just so I know I'd get
back and forth to work
um and other than that that's the only
that I have that's probably around
twenty five thousand uh but I'm just
obviously noticed you know every other
paycheck is I get paid twice a month
that I'm living paycheck and I just
don't know where this money is going
other than me just blowing it because I
never had it
um and everybody gives me advice and I
just was trying to see what all y'all
had to say about it
well dude I I I've got my opinions on
the railroad man so I'm I I know the
work you do is hard and it is
unforgiving and I actually understand
when you say I got to get a car because
I can't not show up because I know about
all that mess
um
can you if George and I walk you through
this will you make us a promise that you
will never listen to knuckle-headed
advice from somebody in the yard ever
again
yeah I promise all right because this is
you've been listening to them and here
we are right so you're gonna listen to
two Knuckleheads on the radio instead
fair enough
all right so you told us you're like I
don't know where my money's going man I
get these paychecks they disappear and
they're big paychecks give us some
guesses as to where the money is going
if you had to rank them from most
frivolous here's where I know it's going
to lease give me like the top three
let's say uh we I still live at home
with parents me and my girlfriend both
live with that with my parents uh we
like to go kind of get out of their way
when we go out and eat that's a big
thing eating out
yeah and then
um just trying to live being young we go
to you know water parks or places like
that
um you know and things that you know you
wouldn't think the cost that much but
just going out just enjoying the time we
have
um
so I say like you're just going and
paying for like water parks or museums
and stuff like that are traveling I
guess would be a good way to say it
um
and then whenever I actually have the
time off it's going to get to off days a
week yeah um so where I mean you don't
even have rent and you're blowing 120
Grand a year
what's your car payment
I pay 595 a month on my car okay so
that's one place your money's going
that's a big chunk
in my insurance I pay for
unfortunately mine and my mother's
vehicle and it's around it's about 500 a
month as well so technically I'd say
it's about a 900 payment because you
really had to have to go because you got
that all right that ends August 15th
here's why you're gonna get out and get
yourself an apartment you make 123 000
no more living at Mommy's house okay
you know what helps you stop spending
when you have real bills like rent to
pay and that goes uh you know we can't
eat out as much because we got to pay
rent yes but you get out of mommy's
house from this point forward okay and
here's here's why I'm telling you that
you're changing your family tree
and if you and girlfriend
and girlfriends loving the fact that
you've won the lottery making 125 000 a
year your parents are loving the fact
that you made 125 I mean this sounds
like a movie you hear that right
well I know yeah I know yeah all right
you have to decide I'm done with this
life
I'm gonna get my own place I'm gonna
start budgeting my money I am going to
take control of this because I have a
lottery ticket and by the way there will
come time
when the railroad slows way way way down
it is right now we're actually they've
just started changing our schedule
they're gonna start and you're gonna be
sweeping the yard
I've got somebody that I love and care
about who had to go move to another city
to get work
right so that they could they could get
on on the board so here's the thing
you're gonna have to create some a
significant savings really like a farmer
because there's years when it rains and
years when it doesn't right
right
do you have any money in the bank right
now
you know
I know okay I know here here's what we
need to do number one this car needs to
get paid off as soon as possible I'm not
going to tell you to sell it because I
think you can pay it off quickly with
this income but that means yeah this you
know what's your take-home pay are you
getting Seven Grand a month
uh I say let's see it's usually about
anywhere from
three thousand to oh close to four
checks so I'd say I'd say about 7 500 to
8 000 a month okay so here's what we
need to do we need to start sending six
grand a month to that car lender
six thousand a month you hear
oh yeah which means we're going to cover
insurance and is is covering mom's
insurance long term is this like a quid
pro quo because you're not paying rent
or what
uh it's yeah you know it kind of I mean
it's literally one of those where you
don't you know you live here so you can
help do this kind of thing right that's
why you don't live there no more that's
why you do not live there yeah yeah so
it's you're not really living rent free
when you owe someone else's insurance
payment
so right that's number one we gotta
start throwing a whole bunch of money at
this car loan debt snowball you only
have one loan you said that's it you're
only debt
you know what's going to help your
spending cutting up that credit card and
sticking to cash and debit cards
I'm telling you that changes the game
because when you swipe that debit card
it's your own money you think
differently when you hand over another
hundred dollar bill
at the grocery store when you're eating
out it hits differently so those are the
two things you got to do today
the other thing I'm going to do is gift
you if you're willing to use it you got
to promise me you're going to use it is
every dollar premium that is our
budgeting tool and it has all these
awesome features like paycheck planning
it connects to your bank account you can
drag up all the transactions and the
categories and this needs to be like
your new hobby is just tracking
transactions everything you spend and if
it's not on the budget because you said
you're going to spend 200 on groceries
this month then it doesn't happen and by
the way when you're in debt you're not
eating out you got One Singular goal and
it's to get out of that car debt and
that's going to make your girlfriend
hate you isn't it
like it used to be so fun we used to go
out and have fun you're like yeah I'm
broke I have no expenses and I still
can't make my paychecks work which means
if you want to be with a man who can
take care of you he's got to figure his
crap out right all right now and hey I
want you to hear what I'm going to say
because
um I've been making jokes and laughing
I'm being very serious okay
okay upwards of 70 of lottery winners go
bankrupt
wow millions and millions of dollars and
they go bankrupt they lose everything
wow because of two reasons number one
they did not come up with a plan for
their money
in all those millions and millions of
dollars did was magnify who they already
were and who they already were with
someone who just spins recklessly and
spends money they don't got and takes
out loans and gets whatever they want
doesn't say no and all that stuff the
second reason people who win the lottery
go bankrupt is they're surrounded by
leeches
people who want a piece and want a peace
and want a peace and I'll even go a
third and I'm gonna I'm gonna say
altruistically
it feels good when you just pick up the
tab for everybody doesn't it feels
awesome
right yeah and when you can take your
girl out anywhere you all want to go
we're gonna go to Sizzler tonight honey
and she's like all right no more Arby's
for us we're going to Golden Corral
right I mean it feels awesome right
right right right right
people get used to that it becomes an
entitlement and then it's hey will you
pick up my insurance hey you got to pay
groceries hey you got to pay the light
bill because suddenly you're everybody
else's cash register so I want you to
take the stuff George has given you for
free and internalize it in your soul and
come up with a plan for this money so a
decade from now the entire family tree
you come from is different because you
made six figures and you worked that
money in uh you're intentional with that
money hang on the line we'll gift you
one year of every dollar premium that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]